смуга перешкод стрільба і тактичні
військові прийоми так у Києві
протестували зразки жіночої польової
форми а зробити це покликали журналісток
українських та іноземних видань разом із
військовими Зараз цю форму тестують у
Міноборони України
Це дуже важко і дуже добре що є жіночі
штани на мені форма буде дуже активно на
виснаження іти по тим всім позиціям на
полосі перешкод які будуть і вже
безпосередньо цей буде показово для того
для вас всіх що таке форма чи вона
тримається чи вона рветься чи вона
зручна якщо вона не зручна вона обтягує
вас пересування і може не дати вам
можливість швидко змінити позицію або ви
можете зачепитися будь-за що по-друге
форма має бути захищена максимально від
того щоби якщо в разі буде якийсь
попадання арт-то обстрілу і будуть якісь
там можливості загорання її вона не має
горіти вона не має тліти вона не має
прилипати до кожної людини
одразу під час проходження мною перешкод
адже потрібно було стрибати бігти
дертися на гору та лізти в окопі це при
тому що ми долали перешкоди без
додаткового навантаження на відміну від
жінок на передовій
штани протестували
якби на мені було на три розміри більше
я не уявляю як прилазити в окопі і ми
просто напевно застрягала ця форма
пошита за спеціальними лекалами для
жінок військових а завдяки тканині
ріп-стоп вона не горить не промокає і не
рветься вчитель приталений у штанах
спеціально висока посадка є достатньо
місця для стегон під колінами є липучки
завдяки яким можна зробити штани довшими
чи коротшими такі ж липучки є Наталії що
припасувати розмір під себе жіноче
тілобудова значно відрізняється від
чоловічої в жінок зазвичай вужче плечі в
жінок є далі в жінок шишки бедра і це
все потрібно враховувати
при пошитті форми насправді це про
повагу це про зручність та Комфорт при
виконанні бойових завдань бо ця війна
чітко показала що жінки їх можуть
виконувати і виконують на рівні з
чоловіками на передовій наша форма е-е
пошити з дуже якісною тканини ця тканина
відповідає всім стандартам Міністерства
оборони її склад 65% котону і 35%
поліестру за рахунок цього вона дихає
загалом музею сум нині служать 60 тисяч
жінок і їм досі видають чоловічу
військову форму та білизну за
виправлення цієї ситуації взялися
волонтери перші зразки форми яку
розробила ініціатива армбімен-нау
випробували на передовій чотири з
половиною тисячі жінок військових серед
них Аліна яка від початку
повномасштабної війни разом із сестрою
приєдналася до лав ЗСУ у перші два
місяці вони ходили взагалі без форми а
далі жінкам почали видавати чоловічу яку
доводилося перешивати Це вже другий мій
комплект
він був супер зручним він пройшов зі
мною бахмуцький напрямок
дуже зручно комфортно не обмежує в руках
тому що талія підвищена а чоловічі штани
ви знаєте вони такі і вони спадали тут
все зафіксовано ти мобільна рухлива це
була б дуже чудово якщо всі жінки були
забезпечені формою всіх розмірів тому що
є різні розміри і вона тобі підійде
потім бойових умовах і ти будеш
комфортно себе відчувати на бойових
завданнях це дуже важливо жіночу
військову форму розробили за стандартами
НАТО проте її максимально адаптували до
української статутної форми Коли ми
пошили перший екземпляр форми кітель
відрізнявся зовнішньо від нашого
статутного там було трішки інші кишені в
натівських формах вони не використовують
застібки і липучки вони використовують
ґудзики І власне ми намагалися
адаптувати форму до українських реалій
тому що в нас є свої вимоги які
передбачені наказом міністерства оборони
вся форма була розроблена враховуючи
стандарти НАТО але із побажаннями наших
захисниць і кінець кінцем ми дійшли до
того що наприклад нагрудні кишені які
є в нашій формі які є в чоловічому
українському однострої вони значно
зручніше за ті кишені які є на формі
НАТО тобто
наразі Україна на жаль вже має такий
досвід яким сама може ділитися з
країнами НАТО та іншими країнами за
їхнім бажанням а не тільки брати чи їх
досвід
Міноборони вже схвалило і рекомендувало
до впровадження жіночої спільні білизну
виготовлену армбіменау тепер на черзі
літня жіноча військова форма на мені
літній жіночий польовий костюм у кольорі
мультикам такий же тільки у кольорі
Піксель зараз знаходиться на фінальній
стадії і затвердження у міністерстві
оборони і вже зовсім скоро така жіноча
уніформа може бути запроваджена для
жінок військових
усі лекала і розробки вже передали в
Міністерство На їхній основі там мають
зробити зразок еталони і провести тендер
далі почнуть відшивати жіночу військову
форму і забезпечувати нею захисниць
країна яка активно рухається до того щоб
вступити до Альянсу НАТО повинна
працювати над тим щоб в Українській
армії було гендерно-орієнтоване
забезпечення для того щоб кожна жінка
почувалася комфортно і була ефективною
при виконанні бойових завдань тому що в
першу чергу це власне повага до гідності
жінок